[Music]
Porto Rico is still dealing with the
devastating effects of Hurricane Maria
nearly 16 months after the deadly
category 4 storm slammed ashore 3.2
million Americans live in the u.s.
territory in 2017 Puerto Rico had 710
homicides that's more per capita than
any u.s. state last year though the
number dropped to 641 but so far this
year 22 people have been murdered on the
island David beg nose in Dorado with a
look at the island safety challenges
David I've been to Dorado at the resort
where you are so I know you're safe
there but other places not so good not
so good Gale look this is paradise we
know that but there are a lot of real
problems here that people have asked us
to talk about in fact when we plan this
trip for Hamilton I went on social media
and I asked folks what's the number one
story we can dig into for you and what
we heard more than anything else was
crime so we have spent the last five
days focusing on that and talking to key
players some of whom believe there is a
crisis of violence on this island and
videos like the one I'm about to show
you are why a lot of people are afraid
here
this is not a war zone
it's San Juan Puerto Rico last Sunday
gunfire erupted in an area frequented by
tourists near the airport a man is
killed in the middle of the street by a
gunman who shoots him again as the
driver flees the next day two brothers
were shot when a driver pulled up and
opened fire in broad daylight then
Wednesday a gunman walked up to a man in
his car at a gas station in Dorado and
killed him at 8:40 in the morning do you
feel safe walking on the street at night
no Kira
Nieves Pearson walked with us through
the tourist area of condado she used to
live here
it's not even perception it's literally
it's my husband getting held up at
gunpoint it's my mom getting carjacked
you know it's everybody that I love has
been a victim and it's happening here
Douglas left is the top FBI official in
Puerto Rico
he says the island is facing a crisis of
violence what percentage of homicides
here on the island are gang-related
sadly it's it's pretty close to a
hundred percent left told us the motives
behind almost every killing our money
survival and drugs they could send the
entire FBI down here and they would
still be overworked that's just the
situation that we have here you can now
go to a precinct and sometimes you only
find one police officer Colonel Michelle
Fraley was the superintendent of the
Puerto Rico Police Department in 2017
during Hurricane Maria she asked if one
of our armed security guards would
escort her to our interview because she
doesn't go outside after 6:00 p.m.
personally at night I don't leave my
house unless it's an emergency that I
have to go to the hospital that is a
hell of a statement
from the woman who used to be the head
police it is what it is I'm not hearing
anybody say what can specifically be
done to make this better
it's very easy the government has to set
priorities a couple of weeks ago half a
million dollars were taken out of the
salary account from the police
department and move to the fire
department they're robbing Peter to pay
Paul correct who's gonna work in a place
that you're gonna risk your life for
everybody and you don't have no benefits
no money they don't pay extra hours
that's veteran Puerto Rico police
officer Julio Centron Hernandez he's
planning to resign in June but for now
he's using his paid time off to work at
a warehouse in Florida I'm talking about
thousands of co-workers they'd be
resigning and they've been jumping to
United States to find some work decent
work with benefits how many police
officers have left the force in the last
10 years 10,000 10,000 yeah
sergeant Gregorio Matias represents one
of seven police unions here
he says the officers who are still
serving are demoralized overworked and
underpaid just last week a police
officer went into a bank and took a
hostage saying he wanted to send a
message no one was hurt
that's something right all right so the
Puerto Rico Secretary of Public Safety
Hector pescado told us this in writing
he does not believe there is a crisis of
violence he thinks these social media
videos are highlighting sort of a larger
problem that he doesn't think exists and
he says at the end of the day this
bankrupt island is having to cut every
department including the police but Gale
the real issue here is so many police
officers continue to leave the island by
the hundreds
I talked to 10 of them just this week
who left the island and left their
families behind in search of better pay
and benefits oh it's such a beautiful
island with beautiful people but that's
a very grim picture you painted thank
you very much David you can hear more of
David's conversation with Douglas Levin
he's a top FBI official that you just
saw in David's piece on today's CBS this
morning podcast it's available on
Apple's podcast app and all major
podcast platforms quite a report